[Music]
we are all talking this week about your
sister Beyonce and her just raw and so
unfiltered words and vogue and what she
also did for the culture right now what
do you think about that I know you're
proud of her but what are you definitely
proud I remember looking at a vogue
magazine cover and I saw three beautiful
white women on the cover and it says
this is what beauty looks like if I'm
not that color how am I supposed to know
what beauty looks like so when we see
we're in a photo on magazine covers but
they're gracing vogue and it's about so
pop culture driven and this is what
beauty is like and we're what beauty is
I'm extremely excited extremely excited
for young girls of color to see that and
understand and know that you are
beautiful what does that mean for a
woman just to have that power in a
situation like that to create her own
culture in that moment and I think we
know I mean of course through that cover
but just as a woman as a black board and
it's a beautiful thing and that's what
we celebrate there's never been a black
cop in this city we think you might be
the man to open things up around here
et also spoke with the 37 year old about
why she chose to come show her support
at the black clansmen red carpet I keep
seeing the the previews on television
and I just want to know what is it about
the last like film I saw was a sweet
blood of Jesus and I follow his work of
course but I'm really excited
you